Trascrizione: Allison Lobina
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Viviamo la divergenza di due mondi.
La divergenza del fare,
che è composta da quell’arte incredibile,
chiamata artigianalità.
Un'arte che tramandata da secoli,
da decenni, di famiglia in famiglia.
Che è fatta di sudore, di tatto,
di emozioni tramandate
di famiglia in famiglia,
che hanno reso straordinario,
in tutto il mondo,
la capacità di trasformare
semplici oggetti
in qualcosa di unico e irripetibile.
Dall'altra parte, siamo stati catapultati
in un concetto del fare
totalmente digitalizzato.
Stiamo parlando di metaverso,
NFT, criptovalute.
Un mondo nuovo, tutto da scoprire,
dove il fare è stato
trasferito al nostro avatar.
Dall'altra parte
la divergenza dell'essere,
la divergenza che tocca
le corde più profonde
del nostro modo di essere.
L'Organizzazione Mondiale della Sanità
ci sta dicendo, molto chiaramente,
che siamo più fragili:
l'organizzazione ha infatti sottolineato
che ansia e depressione stanno
incrementando in maniera vertiginosa:
siamo più deboli.
Dall'altra parte,
l'Intelligenza Artificiale
si sta sostituendo a noi.
La cosa incredibile è un cervello esterno
che sta prendendo le decisioni
in maniera veloce, profonda e automatica.
Passando da un pensiero autonomo,
indipendente, umano
a un pensiero attraverso una macchina.
E se la cosa non mi fa riflettere,
la potenza di queste vetture -
la potenza di queste macchine
aumenterà di oltre cinque volte
nei prossimi anni.
Siamo in una vera Rivoluzione Industriale.
E quindi, mi sono chiesto:
come potremmo far tesoro del passato,
ma portare il meglio di noi nel futuro?
E mi sono chiesto, soprattutto,
che ruolo devono avere le nostre emozioni?
Ma prima di affrontarlo,
mi piacerebbe fare qualcosa con voi.
Mi piacerebbe fare un piccolo esercizio.
Quindi vi chiederei,
tutti insieme, di alzarvi.
Vi chiederei di sentire,
con due battiti di mano,
chi di voi utilizza la palestra
per alimentare parte del proprio corpo.
Al mio tre, voglio sentire
due forti battiti di mano.
Uno, due, tre!
(Applauso)
Wow.
Adesso voglio sentire, invece,
chi alimenta la parte
più intima e intellettuale.
Chi studia, chi legge, chi allarga
la parte profonda della propria mente?
Chi allarga la palestra
della propria mente?
Al tre: Uno, Due, Tre!
(Applauso)
Wow.
Ok, potete accomodarvi.
L'esercizio, di cui
vi ringrazio, è straordinario
perché avete dimostrato
l'energia e l'intensità
della palestra che applicate
tutti i giorni.
E oggi vi vorrei portare,
invece, in una nuova palestra.
Una palestra più leggera,
più intima, più profonda.
Una palestra che tocca
le corde dell'anima,
e le emozioni che la compongono.
Già, l'anima e le emozioni.
Le emozioni sono intorno a noi.
Le emozioni sono in tutto
il nostro percorso, dalla nascita.
Sono nel momento in cui iniziamo
il primo giorno di scuola,
ed arrivano da ogni ragazzo,
da ogni ragazza che inizia
il percorso lavorativo.
Iniziano sempre dal primo giorno.
Pensiamo a quel ragazzo,
o a quella ragazza,
che inizia il primo giorno di lavoro.
Deve assolutamente capire due cose:
uno, come gestire le nuove emozioni
per incrementare la parte
delle sue competenze.
Ha finito il percorso di studi,
ma non ha idea di quale
specializzazione vuole raggiungere.
Ed ecco che con intensità,
grazie all'approfondimento, lo studio,
entra in un'azienda,
cerca di capirne le logiche,
cerca di capirne le tecniche
e cerca di capire tutto ciò
che all'Università
non gli hanno insegnato.
Emozioni legate alla parte più profonda
dell'allargamento
delle proprie competenze.
Dall'altra parte, le emozioni non scritte.
Capire quelle emozioni,
e quelle regole non scritte,
che comportano il regolare
gli equilibri dentro un'azienda.
E quindi il rapporto con il collega,
il rapporto con un capo,
il rapporto con se stesso.
Domandandosi se è la sua strada,
se la strada che sta
percorrendo è quella giusta.
Ed ecco che con intensità,
con resilienza, con percorso,
grazie alle persone
che ci sono state di fianco,
quel ragazzo può ottenere
i primi risultati,
e magari trovarsi a gestire
i migliori brand del settore
che rappresenta nel mondo.
Oppure, ancor di più, ricevere una lettera
dell'A.D. della multinazionale
che rappresenta,
dal nome Sergio Marchionne,
che lo nomina tra i più giovani manager
della multinazionale che rappresenta.
Oppure, ricevere un premio
da un'associazione esterna internazionale,
che lo nomina una rising star.
Wow!
Quel ragazzo sono io.
E sono orgoglioso di chi
mi ha dato l'opportunità,
e sono orgoglioso e grato
del percorso fatto fino ad ora;
ma non mi basta.
Mi sono chiesto e domandato
quale deve essere e come deve essere
il manager del futuro.
Mi sono chiesto come possiamo
far evolvere la nostra parte emotiva,
per portare il meglio di noi nel futuro.
Vedete, il percorso di ognuno di noi
passa da questa strada:
passa dalla capacità di utilizzare
la propria leadership.
La leadership è un privilegio,
e come tale va utilizzata per donarla.
Lo sport, in questo,
è qualcosa di incredibile.
Lo sport è palestra di vita,
è una palestra che ci permette
di rappresentare benissimo
quello che deve accadere con noi
nella vita quotidiana,
in un'azienda e una famiglia,
in un gruppo di amici, in una relazione.
E in tutto lo sport,
se noi analizziamo i numeri uno,
possiamo vedere benissimo
che è la tecnica che li rende eccezionali.
Lo studio minuzioso dei fondamentali,
la tecnica maniacale, ogni giorno,
li fa diventare là,
li fa stare nell'Olimpo di quelli
che rimangono sempre e costantemente là.
Pensiamo a un grande giocatore,
che poi diventa un grandissimo
allenatore di una squadra.
Quindi, la domanda è:
benissimo la tecnica,
ma cos'è che li rende così speciali
da lasciare il segno,
da lasciare il segno nel mondo?
L'empatia.
L'empatia è quella formula magica,
quella magia che fa sì
??che di portare con sé
una squadra se stesso??
e relazionare nella parte
più intima di noi stessi
nel canalizzare nel modo giusto
le nostre emozioni.
Vedete, ho osservato nel mio percorso
tantissimi manager, genitori,
startupper, imprenditori
con incredibili doti tecniche.
Ma non hanno affrontato un percorso tale
per cui i propri talenti
non fossero schiacciati,
in maniera pesante,
da quello che erano i propri blocchi.
Hanno tenuto soffocato
dentro di sé i propri talenti.
Non hanno trovato l'energia
di andare a scavare nella parte più intima
della propria intelligenza emotiva.
Socrate in questo
era stato molto lungimirante:
aveva già intuito che tutto parte da noi.
Aveva già intuito che il percorso
di conoscere se stesso è la chiave.
E quindi, il viaggio inizia da qua.
Inizierà un percorso
dove Socrate ci stimola,
ma dove in realtà gli studiosi,
come Cartesio già dal '600,
avevano capito che l'equilibrio
tra intelligenza
ed emotività, ed emozione,
è un equilibrio
molto difficile da gestire.
Passiamo da Socrate,
che addirittura diceva
che la parte emotiva era un peso,
era un qualcosa che soffocava
la parte razionale, che doveva decidere.
È l'intelletto che ci fa prendere
le decisioni più importanti:
basta, le emozioni sono un problema.
Poi, passiamo ad adamasio,
che dice tutt'altro: dice no,
l'equilibrio tra emozioni
e intelletto è la nostra forza.
Non c'è un primo, non c'è un secondo:
c'è un perfetto mix
che ci permette di raggiungere
il risultato migliore
nel viaggio della vita.
Poi arrivimo ai tempi moderni:
Goleman ha messo invece, al centro,
l'Intelligenza Emotiva,
ha messo al centro la capacità
di gestire le proprie emozioni
in maniera chiave
per esprimere al meglio
la nostra esistenza.
E ha distinto tre aspetti:
uno, riconoscere le proprie emozioni
nel momento in cui vincono,
nel momento in cui le viviamo,
nel momento in cui passano
tra il corpo e la mente dello spirito,
le braccia e le emozioni delle gambe.
Avvertiamo cosa stiamo vivendo.
Due: canalizziamole,
non facciamocene schiacciare.
Canalizziamo quell'incredibile
energia propulsiva
che è dentro di noi in quel momento;
ma canalizziamole
in qualcosa di costruttivo,
facciamo in modo che quell'energia
diventi l'elemento di propulsione
verso noi stessi, verso il mondo.
Terzo, l'empatia e il dialogo.
L'uomo è fatto per essere
un animale sociale,
quindi doniamo, capiamo le emozioni altrui
e facciamo attraverso il dialogo
i passaggi per migliorare la società.
Vedete, sono già cosa state pensando:
va bene, grande!
Ci hai fatto alzare,
abbiamo fatto un po' di palestra,
ci siamo sgranchiti le mani,
ma io non ho tempo!
Ho gli impegni, il figlio, tanto lavoro:
il tempo non ce l'ho, per fermarmi.
Seneca ribalta questo concetto:
di nuovo, il passato.
Torniamo lì.
Seneca è stato così lungimirante
che ci ha detto che invece il tempo c'è.
C'è eccome!
È che molto spesso lo usiamo
nell'ignavia e nella pigrizia.
Non abbiamo la forza di riuscire a trovare
l'equilibrio tra il tempo e lo spazio.
La pandemia ci aveva fatto soffrire molto:
la pandemia ha bloccato un globo intero.
Ma ci ha dato una grande opportunità:
di rimettere al centro
di quel tempo che abbiamo,
le emozioni che ci fanno battere il cuore.
Riportare al centro
quella parte più intima
che fa riportare l'uomo al centro.
Ma so anche cosa state pensando:
va bene, il tempo forse lo posso trovare.
Ma il secondo grande blocco
che l'uomo è capace di mettersi da solo
è il vittimismo.
Ah.
Il problema non è mai nostro,
il problema è degli altri:
sono gli altri che ci devono capire,
sono gli altri che devono comprendere
il nostro stato d'animo.
Io non ho problemi.
Non è proprio così.
La verità sapete qual è?
È che andare in profondità,
nella parte più intima della nostra anima,
fa una paura incredibile.
Andare a toccare quelle corde
profonde del nostro essere
è la parte più difficile
del nostro vivere quotidiano,
quindi è meglio riempirla
di tante altre cose.
Dobbiamo andare lì, scavare,
avere il coraggio di tuffarci
nella nostra anima.
Ed andare a toccare un'emozione per volta.
Abbiamo attraversato la vita,
e abbiamo visto fino adesso
che ci sono tre pilastri
che la riassumono.
Corpo: siete stati bravissimi,
avete dimostrato un'energia pazzesca.
Tutti alleniamo il corpo,
tutti dedichiamo quell'attenzione
incredibile per essere belli.
Due: la mente.
Vogliamo incrementare
le nostre competenze: perfetto.
Terzo pilastro: l'anima.
Il momento di cambiare, però, è adesso,
il momento di prendere
l'opportunità è ora,
perché o saremo in grado
di crescere come collettivo
o saremo annientati individualmente.
O prendiamo la forza
e il coraggio, insieme,
di fare il grande salto, partendo da noi,
o perderemo per strada
la nostra direttrice.
Quindi, è giunto il momento di entrare
in quella famosa palestra
di cui dicevo all'inizio.
Alleniamoci: è giunta l'ora
di prendere l'inizio,
di iscriversi in una palestra.
Sapete qual è il titolo
di questa palestra?
"Tu. Tu. Tu."
La palestra e te stesso.
Sapete qual è il corso?
"Un'ora con la mia anima".
E poi c'è un bellissimo programma:
"Listen, learn e lead."
Listen: ascoltiamo,
incominciamo ad ascoltare
in maniera attiva.
Sediamoci, spegniamo il telefonino,
proviamo a fermare quel diabolico
sistema di social network
per tornare a toccare
la persona che ci è vicino.
Facciamola quella telefonata,
quella chiacchierata
con quella persona
che abbiamo sempre rimandato;
e facciamolo con la grazia del cuore,
con la gentilezza nel cuore.
Cerchiamo di capire veramente,
quella persona davanti a noi.
Cosa ci vuole trasmettere?
Learn: siete venuti, ed oggi
vi siete messi tutti in gioco.
Siete fantastici, avete trovato
la chiave di volta
per cambiare prospettiva.
Per capire in tre ore,
in un fantastico teatro come questo,
come cambiare prospettiva nella vita.
Ed è esattamente il cambio di prospettiva
che si impara mettendosi in discussione,
come avete fatto voi,
è il cambio di prospettiva che vi aiuterà
a rialzarvi più velocemente.
È la capacità di vedere,
quando ci sono le difficoltà,
le cose da un altro punto di vista.
L'ultimo: probabilmente,
alla fine dell'esercizio,
il passaggio più importante: lead.
Guidate, trasferite,
al vostro compagno, al vostro team,
alla vostra squadra,
a vostra moglie, marito, figli,
trasferite questa energia
creando un circolo virtuoso
che permetta di tirar fuori il meglio
della persona che vi è accanto.
Aiutate le persone
a tirar fuori i loro talenti;
tirate fuori le energie e aiutateli.
Perché voi siete leader,
e tutti noi siamo leader,
per poter donare la leadership.
Abbiamo detto che la leadership
è un privilegio: usiamola.
Quindi, per concludere,
la vita è una sola, abbiamo detto.
Scegliamo di essere.
Scegliamo di costruire
il nostro capolavoro.
Perché, come dice Papa Francesco,
non sottraete i talenti
e i doni che Dio ha donato.
Non abbiate paura
di costruire cose grandi.
Buon allenamento a tutti.
(Applausi)